[موسيقى
] العام الجديد يجلب معه جولة جديدة من التهديدات
من ديكتاتور كوريا الشمالية الذي سيبلغ
39 عامًا قريبًا كيم جونغ أون مشيرًا
إلى التهديد المتزايد الذي يتصوره
من الولايات المتحدة وكوريا الجنوبية يدعو إلى
زيادة الأسعار في
البلاد.  الترسانة النووية والإنتاج الضخم
للأسلحة النووية التكتيكية يمثلان
مشكلة سيئة بما يكفي لأنه
يفترض أن لديه بعض العشرات من
الأسلحة النووية في الوقت الحالي حتى
لو استمر في البناء في تلك القاعدة ،
فهذا تحدٍ
دعا كيم أيضًا إلى  قال تطوير نظام
صاروخي باليستي جديد عابر للقارات
لمحللي كوريا الشمالية إن كيم
قد اختبر زوجًا من الصواريخ الباليستية التي
يعتقد أنها قادرة على ضرب
الولايات المتحدة القارية ، لكنه لا يزال
بحاجة إلى تحسين قدرة تلك
الصواريخ على العودة إلى
الغلاف الجوي للأرض.  فيما يتعلق بإعادة الدخول ،
فهذا أمر مثير للاهتمام
بالفعل حيث أشاروا إلى أن كيم أشار إليه
الأسبوع الماضي أو نحو ذلك ، وهو اهتمامهم
بتطوير نظام إعادة الدخول هذا  ربما
توقف عن تجربته بطريقة ما ،
والتي يمكن أن نراها
في الأيام الأخيرة ، تفاخر كيم جونغ أون أيضًا
بهذا السلاح الجديد المشؤوم
الذي تسميه وسائل الإعلام الحكومية في كوريا
الشمالية اقتباس قاذفة صواريخ متعددة فائقة الضخامة في البلاد
والتي تقول إنه
تم اختبار إطلاقها  خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ،
قاذفة يمكن تحميل مزاعم نظام كيم
برؤوس نووية تكتيكية
وتضع كوريا الجنوبية كلها في نطاق
جمهور كيم في الأسابيع الأخيرة ، لم
يظهر Swagger أي علامات على تراجع أنه
حضر لتوه احتفالات رأس السنة الجديدة
حيث منحه الأطفال الزهور في
منتصفه.  - عضو سابق حيث أشرف على
الإطلاق التجريبي لصاروخ باليستي عابر للقارات كان لديه مع
فتاة صغيرة تعتقد المخابرات الكورية الجنوبية
أنها ابنته كيم جو التي
يُعتقد أنها تبلغ من العمر حوالي 10
سنوات ونادرًا ما شوهدت في الأماكن العامة من
قبل ولكن في السر.  دسيسة القصر
في بيونغ يانغ هائلة
مثلها مثل أي وقت مضى تقارير وسائل الإعلام الحكومية ، طرد كيم للتو
باك جونغ تشان أقوى
مسؤول عسكري في كوريا الشمالية  بعيدًا
عن كيم نفسه ، قد يكون هذا
داخليًا ، أنت تعرف لعبة العروش
داخل كوريا الشمالية ، لم يكن قادرًا
على تحقيق أهدافه ولذا فمن
المحتمل أن يقوم بتغييرات في الموظفين
والشيء الآخر الذي نراه بالطبع
هو أنه  لا يمكن أن يتحمل أي مسؤولية
عن الفشل لذلك يجب أن يكون لديه كبش فداء